hey guys how's it going
so it's uh it's late
on a wednesday night um but apple just
released a
pretty pretty pretty impressive product
so i just wanted to jump in here
um because i feel like it's really
moving in the right direction and it's
actually resolving a lot of the issues
that i talked about in my previous
reviews with the macbook air and the
macbook pro so basically the m1 max
is now available in its own enclosure
without a monitor and with lots of
connectivity plus they double down and
they created a freaking new processor
which is better than the m1 or the m1
max and it's called the m1 ultra
basically what they did is
they were like okay the m1 max is
actually really good
but will be better than one m1 max
two m1 maxes and so they basically put
them together
so
now there's double of everything double
of unified memory double speed double
processor and since it's on a soc system
on chip it has all the benefits of the
low power consumption from the original
schematics you can tell that the m1 max
is designed to be connected with another
m1 max now the m1 ultra has double the
memory bandwidth
20 core cpu 64 gpu you can edit 18
8k videos at the same time so the m1 max
already offers a lot of performance for
the cost the max studio with the m1 max
starts at 2500
and the max studio with the m1 ultra
starts at 4 000.
which is you know it's not a small
amount of money but for what it offers i
feel like it's actually a really good
deal especially if you compare to the
previous mac pros which costs a lot more
now that we have all of these socs with
all of this gpu and cpu at this price
point i really hope that there's gonna
be more software optimization
because i think a lot of industry
professionals would want to take
advantage of these computers because the
problem with the m1 even though it was
you know already quite powerful
the problem was always the software
optimization
especially for architects and what's
really incredible is the design
literally just a aluminum box and it has
the capabilities of a full workstation
so you can put it in your
backpack you can put in your suitcase
and as long as you have a monitor and a
source of power you basically have a
full portable workstation for you with
loads of connectivity on the back you
have four usbc ports
rated thunderbolt 4
and you can connect up to four 5k
monitors and an additional 4k tv screen
who really needs all these monitors i
have no idea but i mean it could come in
useful and they've kept two full-size
usb a ports which is awesome because you
know
people still use those and if you don't
want to buy apple's proprietary monitor
which are beautiful but um a little
expensive it has a hdmi port that you
can connect your own monitor to
you still have a regular size audio jack
for your headphones and your audio
system in the front there's two usb-c
ports and a full-size sd card reader so
to wrap it up i'm super excited for this
if this is a portable
super powerful work machine
and i think it really has the potential
to transform the industry
even the very slow-moving architecture
industry
so we'll see what kind of software
optimization we'll get and i'm also
really curious to see how the
competition is going to respond to this
so yeah super excited
and um let me know what you think what
you think is gonna happen with these new
machines and just another note about
video editing i think this is also gonna
transform the video editing industry and
i think now it's all going to be about
coming up with creative ideas now it
doesn't really matter whether you buy an
m1 pro m1 max or an m1 ultra because i
think all of these machines are actually
capable of delivering amazing quality
and
um really good power for editing yeah so
i just wanted to drop by and deliver
this exciting news um i'm really curious
to hear what you guys think about this
like how do you think this is going to
transform the industry and how do you
think pcs are going to respond to this
yeah i think we live in very exciting
times and i hope i can get my hands on
this machine very soon and just a little
announcement in the next couple of weeks
i'm going to be doing my 100k q a
and i'm also going to be doing some
giveaways
so i'll be announcing them in my
community post and in my newsletter
so if you want to participate make sure
you sign up to the newsletter
and
just keep an eye out for the community
post and stay tuned and if you want to
check out my other macbook reviews i
have one on the m1 air i'll leave it
right here and i have one on the m1 pro
i'll leave right here uh thanks for
watching guys i'll see you guys in the
next video bye
[Music]